همم نبقى ايضا في اطار ما نشاهده من الصور
صوره السيده همم التي يجتبه انها هي من
تقف وراء هذا الهجوم وقد حصلت الجزيره همم
على هذه الصوره ومن زوايا مختلفه همم يعني
التعرف يعني اذا همم لا ادري ان كنت
تشاهدها بشكل همم
عمر ولكن
هل يفترض انه سيكون من السهل التعرف على
هذه السيده في ضوء الاجراءات الامنيه
المتخذه همم حاليا بعد التفجير مباشره
والتي من المفترض ان تكون الاجراءات اكثر
تشددا واكثر استقصاءا عنها
نعم بدايه الحسن نريد ان يشير الى ان هذه
الصور التي حصلت عليها الجزيره كانت قد
صادفت لحظات تصوير احد من اصحاب المحال
واصحاب العمال التجاريه المشرف على الساحه
وحتى حتى صاحب الصور لم لم يدرك ان هذه هي
الشخصيه الا بعد انتشار السور لها في تلك
في وسائل الاعلام التركيه الحقيقه هذا
طبعا من شانه ان يسهل عمل السلطات التركيه
وان كانت كما ذكرنا تتحدث بحذر عن كل
التفاصيل التي تفضي الى الى القاء القبض
عليها ربما ان كان هناك تفاصيل تساعدها في
الخروج من اسطنبول انا اريد فقط ان اذكر
حادثه مهمه حسن انا غطينا الهجوم الذي حدث
على الموقع الليلي في اسطنبول كنا هناك
كانت السلطات تروج لروايه مختلفه تماما عن
ما اتبين لاحقا انه هو الروايه الحقيقيه
ضفت عن تمكني هذا
المنفذ من الهرب من التخفي بازين ماء وانه
ما يزال موجودا ضمن هذا الحين يتبين بعد
ذلك ان السلطات الرسميه كانت تنشر مثل هذه
الروايه حتى ااه حتى تضلل ربما او تشتت من
من خطط هذا المنفس بعد ذلك تمكن من القبض
عليه الان السلطات التركيه ربما تريد ان
تضيق اكثر على هذه المنفذه بعد ان انتشرت
لها هذه الصور حتى حدثت الجهه التي غادرت
منها الميدان مكان هذا التفجير الى مكان
اخر وبالتالي فعلا هذا يساعد اكثر المدن
ربما من شهدها بالتعرف عليها اكثر وتقصير
همم ربما فتره زمنيه للقاء القبض عليها
مره اخرى انظمه المراقبه هنا في تركيا
وايضا السلطات الامنيه اثبت الجداره خلال
الاحداث الماضيه في همم القبض على مثل
هؤلاء واي ضا الوصول الى نتائج سريعه